politics and policing United it's a rare
sight in a dark time Northern Ireland's
five main parties together to support
the chief constable and his wounded
colleague John Caldwell
John remains in hospital where he is
critically ill and heavily sedated last
night I had the chance to speak to
John's wife and his son
they are clearly
heavily affected by what they've gone
through but want to pass on their thanks
both to the people that rendered first
aid in Care at the scene but also in
terms of the outpouring of support from
across the community the first Minister
designate hailed a political Unity so
often lacking here it is so important
and moments like this that we stand
United and we do stand here United as
one voice in our condemnation against
this horrific attack on a police officer
there was a passionate denunciation of
violence from one leading unionist it
was an attack on our society it's an
attack on our children there's an attack
on our peace a hard one piece uh and
it's an attack on the Belfast Good
Friday agreement
but it will not work
the chief Constable admits that this
shooting has sent shockwaves through the
Police Service of Northern Ireland but
after visiting his officers in Oma last
night he said we are a tough and
resilient bunch
they'll need to be confirmation today
that this is a terrorist related
investigation with the new Ira the prime
suspects forensic teams in Omak continue
to examine the sports complex where
their colleague was shot multiple times
after a football training session shot
in front of his young son and many other
children something barely comprehensible
here
it's pointless senseless
I do that in front of children
it's Unforgivable
oh we don't want to go back to that time
again it's just unbelievable just to
stop it everybody's been talking to
completely disgusted and there's no room
for that anymore Omar is finding its
voice the community will gather for a
rally against violence tomorrow morning
their message to the men of violence the
men of yesterday is clear
Stephen Murphy Sky News